traffic to the moon is going to pick up
this year
we think it would be very exciting to
have a base on the moon
space transportation companies from
spacex to blue origin
are teaming up with nasa the moon also
needs infrastructure
let me show you something
[Laughter]
and they have their sights on a valuable
resource hundreds of millions of tons of
water ice
at the poles of the moon some geological
analysts say the market for space water
will be worth 206 billion dollars over
the next 30 years
water is the oil of space this would
allow rockets to move deeper into the
cosmos and eventually go to mars
so how do nasa and its partner companies
plan to do this
first you've got to understand that it
takes a lot of fuel to go to space
the moon rockets in the 1960s were
mostly just
giant fuel tanks because all the fuel it
ever needs
has to be brought from the earth george
sowers is a professor of space resources
at colorado school of mines and he's
been enlisted by nasa to research water
ice mining technology
the importance of having sources of fuel
beyond
earth is due to what we call the tyranny
of the rocket equation
what the rocket equation shows is that
as you increase the amount of velocity
that you want the amount of propellant
that you need to deliver that
increases exponentially turns out the
fuel itself isn't expensive
the cost of propellant is actually only
about 0.3 of the cost of the rockets
or permission so emission costs 60
million dollars
the cost of repellent is only 200 000
what is expensive is the weight of the
fuel
because you need a lot of it to break
through earth's gravitational grip
into space moving mass from earth into
space
is really really hard to do it requires
you know big rockets and harnessing that
power is very expensive
so one way to reduce the weight launched
from earth build a refueling station in
space according to sauer's projection
refueling in space cuts the cost of
every mission by at least 10 to 20
percent
also if you can refuel in space at least
once the rocking can travel
farther and at greater velocity
this concept is already an important
part of spacex's starship design
it can get tankered to fill up its
propellant tanks and so it can depart
from low-earth orbit with 1200 tons of
propellant
your delta velocity is is enough to
transport 350 tons to the surface of the
moon on mars
in practicing in docking with the space
station
spacex has also learned how to
rendezvous and dark
in orbit in a complex environment
because of spacex's experience
nasa has chosen it to help develop
orbital refueling
but to make refueling sustainable the
space agency is looking for alternatives
to transporting fuel from earth
in space resources we have to use them
enter space water we were given a gift
this nearby body called the moon there's
water there
it's in the form of ice jeff bezos's
blue origin team has a nearly 580
million dollar contract from nasa
to design and develop a lunar lander
called the blue moon
which will deliver crew and cargo this
lander will be powered by liquid
hydrogen
today's most common rocket fuel
ultimately
we're going to be able to get hydrogen
from that water on the moon
and be able to refuel these vehicles on
the surface of the moon and use them
by running an electric current through
the water it can be split into hydrogen
and oxygen
when the two gases are combined then
ignited they explode
generating energy which then becomes
propellant
to exploit water on the moon nasa has
created a five-year plan with
international and commercial partners to
set up mining operations
if it can be harvested and utilized it's
a game changer it's a paradigm shift
thomas zerboken is the head of science
at nasa he oversees the moon and mars
is research programs part of all
missions just for
sustaining life and also for fuel
so starting this year two commercial
landers will arrive on the moon
delivering spectrometers to map the
location of water in craters
and measure its concentration next year
we're flying the first attempt at the
mining drill
to the surface of the moon it's called
prime one
we're going to either modify it if we
learn something or kind of as a copy
we're going to also
fly on viper viper is a rover built to
explore the darker regions of the south
pole
it'll search for water ice and start
drilling for samples
by 2024 nasa expects its first lunar
outpost called the gateway
will be under construction this will
serve as a port for landers enroute to
the lunar surface and spacecraft headed
to mars and beyond
so if things go as planned by 2025 nasa
can contract robotics companies to start
mining
and three years later begin water
production on the moon
that surface ice is going to be the
lowest cost and the easiest to get
we can get at it by just heating it up
and sublimating it into vapor and
capturing that vapor
as we go forward there may be a time
where such a
fuel depot is absolutely critical for
what we can do like if we want to go
down to the moon multiple times you know
from the gateway
or from other locations kind of being
able to
pick up fuel is an enabling part
meanwhile there are other experiments to
create propellant in space
nasa's perseverance rover that landed on
mars in february is testing a system to
extract oxygen from the carbon dioxide
rich atmosphere to eventually make
propellant
and a recent study by purdue university
confirms the presence of widespread ice
beneath the surface of mars arcadia
plains region
potentially a source for making fuel and
supporting life
while most scientists say a manned
mission to mars is still a decade away
for now practicing how to use space
resources will be one of many key steps
for humans to eventually set foot on
another planet
you